Hi, I'm Nicola Williams, author of Lonely Planet's new France guide.
The French love food. Take the Michelin chef in Medieval Avenue,...
...who talked to me for four whole hours about tomatoes.
We were on the terrace of his restaurant, overlooking the stone walls of a 14th century palace.
I must have smelled, fondled and sampled every type of tomato in Provence:...
...white, red, orange, amber, yellow, black, green, sage,...
...all ripen to culinary perfection by France's hot  southern sun.
Introducing our best guide book yet...
...with updated maps tested on the world's trickiest streets,...
...easier to read page layouts, a new planning section for planning by time,...
...season, interest and region...
...and in-depth features on the world's most fascinating places.